Is the idea that we don't need withered old prunes like Jeff sessions telling us
what we can put in our bodies.
We don't need that.
That's true.
And,
and,
and that how many Jeff sessions are there and the power structure and then where
it gets really fucking cool man.
Check out David Graber you should have him on the podcast.
My God,
he's fucking brilliant.
He's an author and he,
I'm a philosopher,
I guess you could say,
but uh,
um,
he is incredible.
And he wrote a book called,
I think it's called the Utopia of rules that I've been reading,
which is pretty fucking bad ass.
And uh,
it's just sort of breaking down like the,
um,
the bureaucracy that we're in right now.
Bureaucracy,
all the fucking forms you got to fill out to do just about anything these days.
Like all these fucking forms,
this is insanity.
Right?
Right.
But then where it gets really interesting is right now,
so like in like communists states,
the,
the corporations in the state are kind of the same thing.
So there's these like Ministry of Labor.
The stores are all national stores.
You know,
and so we think that that's not what's happening right now.
But actually because the people who are running,
a lot of the corporations used to be in government and the people who are in
government used to be running these big corporations.
One of the cool points he makes,
and also because the government is making the rules that the corporations are
working by it,
but the corporations are putting their own agents into the state.
He sang the,
actually the line between the state and private companies is really blurry right
now.
They're kind of merging together together,
but we like to pretend that they're separate.
For example,
what's happening right now with the fucking FCC trying to take away the internet
with Verizon,
having one of their fucking a pig drones in a super position of power right now
is trying to take away the freedom of the Internet.
The state can be like we,
the corporations can blame it on clarify what you mean by that because they're
not trying to take away the freedom in the end and they're trying to,
they're trying to get rid of net neutrality.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So what would it just mean is that you will have to probably pay more to access
things that require more bandwidth?
It's going to be,
it's not.
It's going to be what it is now where every website has open access it two
versions,
right?
You get the capitalist version.
I think it's a good idea.
And then you get the tech version,
which thinks is terrible idea.
I almost always go to it towards the tech versus you have to,
but that's the Anaconda.
You know the way an Anaconda kill somebody,
every time you exhale it squeezes in a little bit.
That's all I got right now.
It's the squeeze in is okay.
This fucking Internet.
It sucks.
If you're somebody like Jeff,
she does now.
That's not where the money's coming from.
I think you misinterpreting the whole idea.
It's all just a business thing.
It's like being able to throttle the,
the data and being able to decide like,
like if Netflix wants you on there,
if you want to have Netflix on network,
they wanna be able to work out some sort of a deal.
They don't want to treat Netflix like it's any other sort of streaming service
like you looking at the,
the,
their buzzers business transactions they're looking at in a business sense.
They're not saying the internet sucks.
No one is trying to like squeeze the Internet,
stop it.
What they're trying to do is make more money.
Well,
okay great.
They're trying,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
I do here.
I do know what you're saying,
but I think it's a slippery slope and it's that the idea of the Internet being
treated like,
I dunno,
water,
the Internet being treated like just a thing that no corporation should have any
kind of say that that to me it has to stay like that because the moment some
corporation,
whoever it may be,
it gets to start deciding,
yeah,
you guys need to pay a little bit more.
And if we establish that corporations in the state aren't as separate as we like
to think,
then suddenly there's all kinds of back channels.
They're suddenly there becomes a new way to begin to filter out content and you
could say it's for money.
You start building financial walls around things and you start making things
vanished into the background because they aren't in some big conglomerate that's
paying off the corporations more or whatever.
You just mess up the whole thing,
which as far as I can tell,
it's doing great.
The Internet is great.
This fucking compound you're in right now,
you know,
a lot of it came from the Internet.
This thing we're doing right now,
it's the way the Internet's been working.
Oh Dude.
No one's a bigger proponent of the unit than I am.
I just think when we're talking about these issues,
you gotta be,
you gotta be really like objective,
precise,
what's trying to happen here.
They're not trying to silence dissent.
They're just trying to,
they're trying to make as much money as possible.
I mean,
this is a weird,
tricky time when it comes to information and we do have to be very careful
because it could wind up being like,
Hey,
you get your internet from Comcast will.
Comcast is no longer allow,
you know,
Bubba the laugh after that has your podcast featured on it or you know,
some new streaming service.
It's yet to be discovered.
That will be in the future challenging youtube.
So youtube gets together with Google,
you know,
they're owned by Google and they get together with Verizon and they make it
exclusive for the Verizon network.
If you want to get on youtube,
you have to be on the Verizon network.
I mean,
that's,
this is all inside the realm of possibility.
The deeper level though,
anybody who thinks that government has not been totally captured by corporations
isn't paying attention.
I mean,
that's not news in this country.
you come from Europe and this is one of the things,
the problems I have with anarchists and Libertarians.
I think they're very naive about what the world would look like if there were no
government regulations.
Yeah,
I agree.
Every poison,
every river would be to poison,
to swim in it.
You know,
the air would be fucking cause corporations.
It makes sense for them to dump their shit as near to the factory as possible.
Yeah.
They don't give a fuck about birth defects and dead people that it doesn't
matter.